So we want to begin at November the first 1912. This is volume 11.
Now look at the heading, "The soul who thinks about herself, impoverishes herself."
So this is self-preoccupation, okay? Now self-preoccupation means love isn't there.
You're only concerned about yourself. So being very afflicted because of the
privation of my adorable Jesus, I was praying and repairing for all souls, but
at the extreme of my bitterness I turned the thought to myself and I said, "Have mercy
on me, forgive this soul. Your blood and your pains, are they not mine too?" Do they
perhaps count less for me? And while I was saying this, my beloved Jesus
spoke within my interior. Now notice within my interior, the kingdom of God
is within you. That's Luke 17 21. And this is the very important thing. Now the
Lord allowed her to have that distraction to give us the teaching we need.
And my daughter, he said, "What are you doing, thinking about yourself?"
Because if you think about yourself, the ego is in the center of life. God isn't,
and love isn't, and your neighbor isn't. You are now going down, reducing yourself
from being the owner of the divine will. Now you need to add a few little
words there to make that English from being there.
And then the word, the book says owner, and then you'd have to put up divine will
to the miserable condition of one who asks. Poor daughter, by thinking of
yourself, you impoverish yourself. Because in my will, you are the owner
and you can take anything you want on your own. Now people just don't realize
that the divine will is the essence, not only of God, but of everything.
Nothing can exist without the divine will. And if we're in a position of living
in the divine will, he says you can have what you want.
Somehow Saint Augustine touched on this a little bit when he said love God and do
what you like. But people have totally misunderstood what he's saying.
Because if you love God, you will act freely within that love.
And this is what Jesus is saying to Louisa. If you truly are in this position of
being the owner of the divine will, then of course you can dispose of it.
If I have a packet of money in this house, which you could dream about,
then I can dispose of it the way I want. Why? Because I'm the owner.
If I have flowers in the garden, I can dispose of them as I want,
simply because I'm the owner. But I'm not the owner, I can't do that.
And so this is what he's saying. If you reduce yourself then
to the position of asking, you are acting as if you're not the owner.
If there is anything to do in my will, it is to pray and repair for others.
It is entirely other centered. The divine will is entirely other centered.
You're centered on God and God's love and on your neighbor and on
your neighbor's love. That is the first commandment
and the second commandment that Jesus said to love God and to love your neighbor.
And that's what divine will is in its essence.
And Louise has said, "Most sweet Jesus, you love so much that those who live in
your will do not think about themselves." And she says, "Do you think of yourself?"
And then suddenly she writes, "What an inappropriate question to ask God to
think about himself." And Jesus said, "No, I do not think about myself.
Those who need something think about themselves." Isn't that interesting?
It's a sign of need. Isn't that interesting?
So this self preoccupation is a sign of need.
And someone who is truly living in the divine will,
you don't have needs. They're all your real needs are supplied by the Lord.
And Jesus said, "I need nothing. I am sanctity itself.
I am understood happiness itself. I am immensity.
I am height and depth themselves." Now put in your margin there,
true freedom. If you actually need nothing, you are totally free.
I lack nothing, nothing, he said. So what does he have to think about himself for?
My being contains all possible imaginable goods within itself.
If any thought occupies me, it is for mankind,
which I released from myself and which I wanted to return to myself.
And in all of these revelations, the whole thing is concerned
with the human race coming back to God in the same way as it went out from him.
So he's thinking about us. I have a lovely picture inside.
I'll show it to you if you're interested. And it says that when he was on the cross,
I was on his mind. He was thinking of me.
He was thinking, and each one of us can say he was thinking of me,
because he was there doing that, enduring that,
to make sure that the crown of glory would be put on our heads one day.
Okay, so he was thinking of us. And in the same condition, he said,
"Do I place the souls who truly want to do? That is to live in my will?
They are one with me, and I render them the owners of my goods."
So I want to give you a song of songs to 16. My beloved is mine, and I am his.
He owns me, and I own him. If I own him, I own heaven, don't I?
I own the divine will. So I render them the owners of my goods,
because in my will, there's no slavery. What is mine is theirs.
That's the song of songs to 16 again. And whatever I want, they want as well.
Okay, now in John 8, 36, Jesus said, "If the son sets you free, you are free indeed."
This is all about freedom. Nothing to do with slavery.
Slavery is way back to spirituality's way at the very bottom of the mountain.
And you had to climb that mountain and look up and realize there was a divine will
mountain higher than that and start climbing the divine will mountain.
So it's so far away from where we're at. It's amazing.
So if one feels the need of something, it means that she's not really in my will.
Now you have to do that meditation all by yourself.
So if one feels the need of something, it means she's not really in my will.
You are perceiving that there is something that you actually want.
Or at the most, she makes some descents. Just as you are doing right now, she said,
he said, "Nothing less." Does it not seem strange to you that one who has formed one
single thing, one single will with me, asks me for mercy, pardon, blood, and pains.
When I made her the owner together with me,
you see, Jesus explains in these writings that the reason why the Blessed Trinity is
infinitely, absolutely, unconditionally, eternally happy is that there's one will.
There's only one will. And each of the three of them are loving each other,
infinitely, absolutely, unconditionally, eternally.
What can make a family completely miserable is that you can have five people with five different
wills all operating against each other at some point. And that is what the problem is.
Okay. Jesus said, "I do not know what mercy, what pardon to give her since I gave her everything
already." At the most, I should have mercy on myself or forgive myself some fault, which can
never be. Because if you truly are one with him, how can you say that the thing that's one with him
has some kind of a lack in it? You can't say that. You can't say that. So this is something you
really need to meditate on because we can hardly grasp the fullness of the gift of the divine will.
Therefore, he said, "I recommend that you do not leave my will and that you continue not to think
about yourself, colour that one, but think only about others. Otherwise, you would impoverish
yourself and you would feel the need of everything." Now, I don't have to tell you it's much quicker
to fall down a mountain than to climb up a mountain. But if you do, you can not only injure yourself,
you can kill yourself. The same mountain that would have got you all the laurels for climbing it,
you can fall down and you can be dead at the other end. Or you can be so desperately injured,
and it's the same thing spiritually as well. It's so much easier to fall than to climb.
That's why Jesus says, "Keep going, keep going." So November 2nd, 1912, "How the soul must recognize
herself only in God." So continuing in my affliction, Louisa said, "I was saying to myself,
I no longer recognize myself." Sweet life of mine, where are you? What should I do to find you again?
So that's the song of songs, chapter 3, verses 1 to 4. The bride goes searching for the bridegroom.
It can't tolerate his absence. "Without you, my love, I cannot find the beauty that embellishes
me, the strength that fortifies me, or the life that bivifies me." Now, that's the truth of John
15, 5. Without me, you can do nothing. I lack everything. Everything is death for me. And life
itself without you is more harrowing than any death. It is a constant dying. Come, Jesus,
I can take no more. Or supreme light, come, don't make me wait anymore. Let me feel the touch of
your hands, but as I try to grab you, you escape me. Let me see your shadow, but as I try to look
into the shadow at the majesty and beauty of my sun, Jesus, S.U.N., I lose both the shadow and the
sun, or please have pity. My heart is tortured. It is lacerated into pieces. I cannot live anymore,
if only I could die. And as I was saying this, Jesus came and said to me, "My daughter, I am here
inside of you." That's your Luke 1721, the kingdom of God is within you. But she wants to see him in
three-dimensional form, Luke 1721. If you want to recognize yourself, Jesus said, "Come into me,"
to recognize yourself inside of me. Because we are the mystical body of Christ. Our true recognition
is in him. If you come to recognize yourself in me, you will put yourself in order. In other words,
you'll stop all of this struggling. Because in me, you will find your image that's Romans 829,
Romans 829. Made by me and similar to me, in the margin, I want you to put the divine version
of me is what you'll find. In him, I find the divine version of me.
I like to put out the magic. So in him, I find the divine version of me. You will find everything
that is needed to preserve and embellish this image, all the grace, all the virtues, absolutely
everything. As you come to recognize yourself in me, you will also recognize your neighbor in me.
And you see, this is waking up that I'm not the only one in the divine will. This person is in the
divine will. That person is in the divine will. That person is in. So I begin to recognize my neighbor
in the correct light. I don't just recognize myself. I recognize you. And when each one of
us begins to recognize each other on this level, it has a huge effect on us as to how you actually
relate to this other person, because you're seeing them in the divine mystery that they're
actually involved in. You're not seeing them on the outside. The world looks at you on the outside.
But you're seeing them in the divine mystery that they're actually involved in.
You will recognize your neighbor in me. And in seeing how I love you and how I love your
neighbor, you will rise to the degree of true divine love. Okay, for that, I want to give you John 13.
John 13 verses 34 to 35. This is a new commandment that I give you that you're to love one another
in the same way as I loved you. Okay, that means we've got to love one another divinely.
Verses 34 and 35. That's John 13 verses 34 to 35. So in this way, you will rise to the degree of true
divine love. And everything inside and outside of you will take on the true order, which is the divine
order. So we can only begin to reach out to love the neighbor on a divine level in the divine will.
And so the things you would say and do on this divine level would be very different to what you
would say and do on the human level, because you'll be seeing that person and their needs or whatever
it is in a completely different light, and you'd be seeing it with an eternal reality. And so your
love would be different. Like there are some people on a very low level of love, and they think they're
loving the other person by just giving into them. And that's not love at all, as you know,
even on the absolutely human level, it's not really loving a person you've got to think of a much
higher order than that. So what Jesus says, if you want to recognize yourself inside of yourself,
first, you will not really recognize yourself because you will lack divine light. So you won't
have enough light to see. Second, you will find all things in disorder and clashing among themselves,
misery, weakness, darkness, passions, and all the rest who needs it. It is disorder that you will
find inside and outside of yourself. For these things will wage war, not only against you, but
among themselves, to see that which one can hurt you the most. And imagine yourself in what order
that they will put you with regard to your neighbor. Now, one of the reasons for battles
against other people is that the stuff that's warring in me is hitting out against the stuff
that's warring in the other person. And so you can have absolutely unreasonable wars going on
because there's individual wars going on. And so there can't be understanding between the people
at all. Not only do I want you to recognize yourself in me, Jesus said, but if you want to
remember yourself, you must come and do it in me. Otherwise, if you try to remember yourself
without me, you'll do more harm than good. I think he's made that perfectly clear, hasn't he?
Okay. So I have a VIP on the next one. It's November the 25th, 1912, the two stairways to heaven.
Okay, it's very, very interesting. One is made of wood. For those who follow the path of the human
virtues and one is made of gold for those who live their lives in Jesus. Now, before we even start,
I want to give you John 151 that Jesus is the stairway to heaven. Okay. Oh, I've just remembered.
It's, I think it's one Corinthians now. What? It's around chapter three where Paul says that
on this earth, we can make our heavenly home either in wood or straw or grass or silver or gold.
And whatever, whatever you make on the earth is the thing you're going to have in heaven.
Okay. So if my life is on the level of wood or grass or straw, that's what all I have when I
arrive. But if the life has been lived in the gold of divine love, then you're going to get
out of a palace in heaven. So this morning, it seemed that my beloved Jesus came as usual in
the usual way as before. However, it seemed to me as if he was passing by and was anxious to see me
again to be with me in a familiar way on seeing him so good, sweet. Now, this thing, I've just
remembered as I was looking at this, you'd never think I prepared this now. Sometimes it's only
when I'm actually reading it for the group that the scripture will come to me. It's one of the
great teams of scripture that the Lord is always passing by. And what he wants is for us to invite
him in. Do you remember the two men on the road to Emmaus? Yes. Okay. So that's Luke 24.
And Jesus was meaning to go by and they invited him in and therefore he revealed himself to
them. But it's one of the great teams of scripture that the Lord is passing by. On seeing him so
good and sweet and kind, my book says benign, which we don't use. But what does your book say?
Benign. Benign. I forgot all his worries and about the privations. I think it's very interesting.
Notice what she puts first. I forgot his worries. And then I forgot the privations. No, notice who's
first. And she said, and seeing him with the crown that thorns big and quite thick, I said to him,
my sweet love and my life, show me that you continue to love me, remove this crown that surrounds your
head and put it on mine with your own hands. That isn't anybody's image of Jesus. And beloved Jesus
quickly removed it from his head and with his own hands pressed it onto my head. Oh, I'm happy I
felt with the with the thorns of Jesus sharp. Yes, but sweet. This sharp but sweet means that I do
feel the pain, but the spiritual advantages are so great that it outbalances it outweighs that we
would say. He looked at me with loving tenderness and I seeing myself gazed upon so tenderly,
becoming brave added Jesus my heart. The thorns are not enough for me to be certain that you love
me as before. Don't you have the nails with which to nail me? Now she's looking for proofs of love.
If you're looking for proofs of love, would you be looking for thorns and nails?
Look at the way someone really in the presence of God behaves. It's incredible. Isn't it?
"Hurry Jesus, don't keep me in doubt for the mere doubt of not being ever more loved by you,
gives me continual death." "Pierce me," she said. He said, "My daughter, I don't have nails with me.
And to make you content, I'll pierce you with an iron that's infinitely worse than a nail,
an iron's much bigger and ticker." So he took my hands and ripped them open very far and then
my feet I suffered yes. I felt I was swimming in a sea of pain, but also of love and sweetness.
I noticed the balance every time. If you are swimming in a sea of pain and there's no balance
whatsoever, human nature can't tolerate that. So whenever the victim souls are really suffering,
the Lord balances it with interior sweetness. It seems that Jesus could not remove his tender and
loving gaze from me and placing his royal mantle on me, covering me completely with it, he told me,
"My sweet daughter, cease now any doubt about my love for you."
Even more, in order to give you courage to tell you that no matter what state you are in,
or whether you see me worried or flashing by or silent, remember that one single renewal
of my torns or nails to you will be enough to place us together in our loving closeness and
intimacy more than before. So you can see that her third marriage was to the crucified one.
Remember? In volume one, her third marriage was to the crucified one and therefore she needs these
signs. Therefore be content and I will continue with the scourges in the world.
Do you see that no matter what state you are in, that means whether your prayer is dry or fervent
or whether you feel it's all over or whatever else. Now in volume 16, which we're doing with
another class, he tells Louisa that because she is the first one to live in the divine will after
Jesus unmarried themselves, that he had to let her go through every single state so that he could
close them off and move on into the divine will. Just as Jesus himself had to experience everything
to do with the mosaic law before he could shut it down and close it off and finish it on the cross.
So he did all the reparation and all the fulfillment, absolutely everything. So he told her that's why
she had to go through everything. She had to go through periods of dryness and fervor and all
the rest of it that everybody else goes through. So Louisa has gone through all the stages of prayer
that we go through. But it's not for us and for ourselves, it was for us. He told me other things,
but the intensity of the pain doesn't allow me to remember them well. Pain has an extraordinary
ability to only let you concentrate on it. Then I remained alone again without Jesus and I poured
myself out with my sweet mother crying and praying her to make Jesus come back. Blessed mother told me
my sweet daughter do not cry. You must thank Jesus for the way he comports himself with you
and for the grace he gives you not allowing that you move away from his holy will in these times
of chastisements. Greater grace he could not give you. Now I think you need to put an Irish flag beside
that because you and I are living at a time of the great apostasy and for you and I to be given the
grace to live in the divine will our blessed mother is saying that in these terrible times
greater grace couldn't be given to you and a greater privilege couldn't be given to you. That's why I
say put an Irish flag beside that one and it's very important. Afterwards Jesus came back and seeing
that I had cried he told me why have you cried? It's very interesting isn't it? She's not supposed
to cry. Why? She in volume one she was allowed to cry because she was only a teenager but now
she's the adult who actually asked for the crown of thorns and asked for the suffering. She asked
for her rights if I can put it that way as a victim soul so crying doesn't fit. She says why did you cry?
Because crying either is that I'm sorry for myself or I don't like the pain and I want out or whatever
it is so Jesus is just alerting her to the fact that she needs to be higher than that
and he said I cried with my mother I did not cry with anybody else look at the defense
and I did it because you were not here and Jesus taking my hands in his seemed to mitigate my
pains you see what I'm saying? Crying what seems to say the pain is too much so he mitigated the
pains and then he showed me two high stairways from earth up to heaven now I want to give you
two scriptures okay Genesis 28 verses 12 to 15 Genesis 28 verses 12 to 15 that's Jacob seeing
the stairway to heaven with the angels of God going up and down do you remember
and then John 1 51 is Jesus saying that he is the fulfillment of Genesis 28 John 1 51
Jesus is the fulfillment of that so now we're looking at the two high stairways
so this is people living spirituality on the earth to reach heaven okay now on one of them
there was more people and there was very few on the other so you'd guess already the one with the
very few is the divine will you'd guess that one wouldn't you the one on which there were only a
few people was of solid gold and it seemed that those few who are going up there were as many other
Jesus each one of them was one Jesus that means each person is in union with God okay
the other one on which there were more people seemed to be made of wood now wood is a great
thing but it's of the earth and one could distinguish you with the people where almost all of them
were short and not very developed now she's getting a picture of spiritual growth so the ones who
haven't grown a lot are short they're underdeveloped and the ones who are other Jesus are in their
full development okay so Jesus said my daughter we're going to deal with the golden stairway first
this is the living in the divine will my daughter those who live their lives in my life ascend
on the golden stairways now if you live in the divine will you're going to be living in the life
of Jesus and he's going to be living his life continuing his life in you so i can say they are
my feet my hands my heart my whole self now the church has taught us that from the very beginning
that them were the mystical body of Christ so wear his hands and so on as you can see they are
another me they are all for me notice the all and i am their life their actions are all of gold
and of incalculable value because they are divine so all of those actions count for heaven okay no one
will ever be able to reach their height that means height of sanctity the height of sanctity
in one of the volumes over volume 20 she simply louisa simply refers to the height of the blessed
virgin and having forgotten that it was explained earlier i said to the group what does she mean the
height you know but she meant the height of sanctity okay so i wanted to put it in there so you won't
forget as i did no one will be able to reach their height of sanctity because they are my very life
almost without anyone knowing them because they are hidden in me only in heaven will they be
perfectly known now this group on the golden stairway are living the hidden life of Nazareth
so nobody not even people in your own house know you're there why will they not suspect it because
they'll see the the faults that are on the outside and the lord allows the faults on the outside to
be seen so that people won't be able to touch the treasure that's inside and spoil it so it's a
hidden life okay now the second group on the wooden stairway there are more souls because
you're dealing with ordinary spirituality these are the souls who walk along the way of the virtues
yes but not in union with my life and with the continuous connection with my will now i want you
to notice something and that is that truly living in the divine will demands union with god
it's a very high spirituality it demands union with god so their actions now that we're down on
the the wooden stairway their actions are of wood therefore their value is minimal oh dear
okay these souls are short almost scrawny because many human purposes are mixed in
so they are concerned about themselves and about their own advancement and they're decent by that
and the other many human purposes are mixed in with their good actions and human purposes produce
no growth so here you have the the human will is dominant but just put hw in your margin and in front
of the other the first paragraph put dw divine will so this is divine will versus human will
human will is just put in the in the margin there it's that this whole paragraph is about the human
will whereas the paragraph before it was divine will so jesus says that they're the value of their
actions is minimal these souls are short yet okay they are known to everyone because they're not
hidden in me but in themselves and therefore no one covers them look at the no one covers them i
have a big ring around that for myself i don't own your book so i can't ring it so when we're hidden
in christ he is our covering can you see what he's saying if if you take the sacred host at the end
of mass the little piece of bread is the covering for that divine presence that's hidden inside
is that okay you can see the divine presence you can only see the covering and jesus is saying
that for those of us who live in the divine will he is our covering and that we're living
hidden with christ in god it's absolutely fantastic so i can't remember the the
reference hidden with christ in god all i know is that it's from Ephesians
okay hidden with christ in god and therefore he is our covering is that fantastic so if we're
living a life hidden with christ in god satan is not going to be able to get at us
whereas if you are not hidden and you're out there and there's nobody covering you
satan can get at you very easily they will not cause any surprise in heaven these ordinary ones
since they're well known also on earth therefore my daughter i want you completely in my life
with nothing in yours and i entrust to you the ones uh you know and see uh that they may keep
themselves strong and constant on the stairway of my life so all of those living in the divine will
were actually entrusted to louisa to pray she prayed for us all he pointed to me someone that i
knew and disappeared okay because that was during her lifetime so there you've got the two stairways
and he's telling you that uh the crown and completion of all sanctity is living in the divine will
so let's come to december the 14th 1912 look at the heading one who lives in the divine will
embraces everything praise and repairs for all and takes within herself the love that god has for
everyone is that fantastic you absorb to then yourself the love god has for everyone and you
distribute it to them so this morning when my beloved jesus came he tied me with a golden thread
and told me my daughter i do not want to tie you with ropes and chains shackles and iron chains
are used with rebels but with the docile with those who want no other life than my will and take
no food other than my love just a thread is enough to keep them united with me and many times i do
not even use this thread they are so deeply into me as to form one single thing with me there's your
john 14 20 to 21 you in me and i and you john 14 20 to 21 and if i use the thread it's almost to
play around them jesus said the next paragraph the divine will is in everything and everyone
so if i'm in the divine will i am in everything and everyone while jesus was tying me i found myself
in the endless sea of the will of my sweet jesus and as a consequence in all people because if you're
in the divine will the divine will is in everyone and everything otherwise they wouldn't exist
and i kept going in the mind of jesus in the eyes of jesus in his mouth in his heart as well as in
the minds the eyes and everything else of creatures doing all that jesus did oh how with jesus one
embraces all souls no one is excluded now that's extremely important that statement
there's lots of signs to indicate whether you're in the divine will truly or not and that is you
your thinking becomes universal everything's for everybody do you know what i mean
nobody's left out you don't ask for religion or color or race or language or anything else
everyone is included because that's the way god loves he loves everybody
and in one of the higher volumes jesus says that god loves one person with the exact same love of
which he loves everybody and he loves everybody else with the exact same love with which he loves
that one person so it's it's an amazing thing so jesus added one who is in my will embracing
everything praying and repairing for everyone takes within herself the love that i have for all
the love i have for everyone she encloses in herself and for as much as i love her
she is equally dear to me and beautiful she leaves everyone behind so you absorb all the love that
god has for everyone and you let it be distributed through you all the mercy that he has for everything
that is distributed through you all the precious blood of the lamb you distributed to everybody
we have this incredible privilege you know so you could call us distributors
we make sure that all the benefits get everybody and of course many many many souls
who in their ordinary everyday lives are not going to meet christians and they're not going to
have any way of finding the lord they will receive it directly it's quite amazing
i'm fascinated that if you go on the internet how many Muslims around the world are testifying
that the lord came to them directly and revealed himself i i think that's the result of this kind
of prayer that the grace is given to them directly then having read that one who is not tempted is
not dear to god so louisa is reading stop that's much more inferior to her own life okay and since
it seems to me that for a long time now i have not known what temptation is i said this to jesus
and he told me now we've just read that a person living in the divine will is hidden inside of christ
living a hidden life where is the temptation going to come from you have to be out there exposed to
the world exposed to the self and exposed to the devil to get temptation what if you're living a
life hidden with christ in god that's not going to be but louisa needs all of this clarified for us
so jesus' answer was my daughter one who is completely in my will that's your deuteronomy six
four to ten deuteronomy six four to ten you shall love the lord your god with all your heart all
your soul all your mind and all your being okay so one who is completely in my will is not subject
to temptation because the devil does not have the power to enter into my will that's something
you need to take on board isn't it if i'm inside of the divine will jesus going to explain as we go
along uh that for the devil to touch the divine will is hell for him because hell started with
his rebellion against the divine will he can't cope with any anybody in the divine will so the
devil does not have the power to enter my will not only this but he himself does not want to enter
because my will is light that's one john one five one john one five
and before this light the soul would recognize his tricks very easily and would therefore make
fun of the enemy as a person told me recently when the enemy approached him
and whatever the enemy said to him this person just simply said to the enemy
well listen when all is said and done i think my future is a little bit better than yours
and the devil just scooters is that amazing talk about coming to the point
not wasting one scrap of anti whatever you can say my future is a bit better than yours
see this is what jesus is saying you would recognize the tricks very easily and would
therefore make fun of the enemy okay the enemy doesn't like mockery because his name is pride
which is more terrible for him than hell itself it's very interesting isn't it
so he does all that he can to stay away from the soul try to get out of my will and you would see how
many enemies would swoop down on top of you one who is in my will carries the flag of victory
always high and none of the enemies dares to confront this impregnable flag so i want to give
you one peter one eight to nine one peter one eight to nine and i want to give you one peter five
verses five to nine now one peter five five to nine says if you bow down before the lord
the devil will flee from you okay so december the 20th 1912 jesus gives everything that he is
to one who does his will isn't that amazing he gives everything therefore there are no judgments
for the soul who does his will he's going to say this many times in different ways
the past days my beloved jesus seemed to feel like speaking about his holy will
he would call me to say a few words in any escape i remember that once he told me my daughter
when one who lives in my will i feel as though the duty to give her my virtues my beauty my strength
in a word everything that i am so we we say of people that they become more christlike
his virtues his beauty is everything if i did not give it to her i would deny it to myself
another time i was reading about how terrible the judgment is and as i was left very saddened my
sweet jesus said to me my daughter why do you want to saddened me and louisa said i don't intend to
saden you but myself and he said ah don't you want to understand that displeasure sadness and
anything that one who does my will may suffer falls upon me and i feel them as my own listen
if you are one with person if if these two hands are at one with each other in union with each other
and the right hand is hers did you think the left hand won't feel it it's the same body
so jesus said if you're sad i feel it why are you doing this to me he says true it's just
you know we find it difficult to grasp the enormity of what this union is
and so he said i can say to one who lives in my will my book says does my will but actually means
lives in my will laws are not for you for you there are no judgments now let me give you that
on in a completely different context for people in any country who are living a decent life
and who serve their neighbor and and all the rest of it and carry out their juices the courts are
not for them the prisons are not for them are they the country has no judgment against you
it's only for rebels okay so jesus is saying that for someone who lives in his will
if you go to heaven and you're united with his will where's the judgment what is there to be judged
but you see you probably grew up some of you around the same time as i did and we were told
horror stories about judgment you know what i mean and pre-stomping the the pulpers you know you're
all going to hell therefore not understanding the the mercy of god this is why saint saint
augustan says love god and do what you like because at this level of union with god
you're living in love and the only baggage you can take to heaven with you is love
you're already living the beatitude and jesus going to tell us this more and more
as we go on in the volumes okay so there's no judgment and if i wanted to judge where he said
i would act like one who wanted to judge myself because you're a new union with him on the country
one who does my will or lives in my will instead of being judged acquires the right to judge others
now that's straight out of one carinthians six verses two to three one carinthians six
verses two to three and one carinthians two verse fifteen
it's just important to see how much these writings reflect the scriptures and how much
the scriptures reflect these writings and then he added the goodwill of the soul in doing good
is a power over my heart isn't that beautiful and this power exerts so much leverage on me
that by dint of lever leveraging she forces me to give her what she wants
so the more we live in the divine will and you have something to ask for somebody else you don't
ask for yourself in the divine will uh he'll give it and then louisa said i was thinking
what is jesus like the most love or his will this is very important because the
the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love and he said my will must prevail
in every over everything look at it yourself you have a body and a soul you are made of intelligence
flesh bones and nerves but you're not of cold marble you also contain heat so the intelligence
the body the flesh the bones the nerves there must be my will and the heat which the soul contains
is love look at the flame the fire the flame the fire must be my will while the heat produced by
the flame of the fire is love so you see it's divine will and love so in all things the substance
must be my will and the effects must be love both of them are so connected together that one cannot
one cannot be without the other so the more substance of my will the soul contains the more love she
produces isn't that fantastic see god is love and everything that god does is done in love that's
sam one four five verse seventeen god only ever acts out of love so he created out of love he
redeemed out of love he sanctifies out of love he does absolutely everything out of love and so
the more we are identified with him the more that love takes over and expresses itself through us
okay so let's do January 22 1913 the triple passion of Jesus of love sin and from the Jews
now this is straight the same as the hours of the passion and you'll get the same teaching in the
agony in the garden in the hours of the passion okay I was thinking about the passion of my beloved
Jesus especially a party suffered in the garden I found myself all immersed in Jesus and he told me
my daughter my first passion was of love and the first step because the first step with which man
in sinning gives himself to evil is the lack of love when we step back from love he says that's
the beginning of evil so since love is missing he falls into sin in order to be repaid through
me for the lack of love of creatures love made me suffer more than anyone it almost crushed me
more than if I was under a press okay now the press is usually a wine press but it could be
a null of press so I want to give you a couple of scriptures for that Isaiah 63 3
Revelation 14 verses 19 to 20
and Revelation 19 15 that's the press
so what the scriptures tell us is that Jesus as the grapes of God had to be crushed
to make the the wine of the kingdom of God so it gave me many debts for as many souls receiving
life he said the second step that occurs in sin is defrauding God of his glory
so in order to be repaid for the glory taken away by creatures the father made me suffer the
passion of sin such that each sin gave me a special passion it's not incredible each sin
although there was only one passion I suffered for sin as many passions as there would be sins
committed until the end of the world that to me is impossible to absorb or don't know about you
so the glory of the father was restored the third effect produced by sin is weakness in man
therefore I wanted to suffer the passion from the hands of the Jews my third passion
to restore man his lost strength therefore with the passion of love love was restored
and placed at the right level with the passion of sin the glory of the father was restored
and placed at the right level with the passion of the Jews the strength of the creatures was placed
at the right level and restored I suffered all this in the garden and the pain was so much
so many the death the atrocious spasms inflicted upon me that I really would have died if the will
of the father for my death had arrived I want to give you john for my sorry not john mark 14
41 that when when the agony was over jesus said it's all over
and when someone 41 and when you're reading the gospel and you say to yourself but the
passion isn't even begun and he's saying it's all over it was in fact all over because he had done
everything interiorly and what was to happen on the outside was simply what is called here the
passion of the Jews it's amazing and the passion of the Jews really should be read slightly differently
it's the passion of the people of god because they were the people of god they still are
and up to the the passion of Jesus and then we're the people of god now and he's suffering the
passion from us as well from our sins and in these writings louisa says that Jesus suffers
the passion in the tabernacle all the time that's spiritually that's from all of our sins and everything
so it continues then he continues then I began to think oh louisa said I began to think of when
my beloved Jesus was thrown into the chedron stream by his enemies blessed Jesus made himself seen
in a state that aroused pity all wet with those filthy waters and he told me my daughter in creating
the soul I covered her with a mantle of light and beauty sin removes this mantle of light and beauty
placing a mantle of darkness and ugliness rendering the soul disgusting and nauseating
so when you read this uh when you when you read the detail of what louisa says about
Jesus passion in the hours of the passion Jesus physically looked on the outside what sin looks
like to god that when he came out of those waters he was nauseating and and disgusting and he says
that's exactly how we look in the eyes of god and in order to remove this mantle so filthy
which sin puts on the soul I allowed the Jews to throw me into this stream where I remained as though
enwrapped inside and out because these putrid waters entered even into my ears into my nostrils
and into my mouth so much so that the Jews were disgusted to touch me how much the love of creatures
has cost me to the point of rendering me nauseating even to myself now amazing isn't that amazing now
when I read that I have a problem and people usually look at me when I say I have a problem with
something and the problem is that I can't fathom why an infinite almighty ever living ever lasting
creator who can create the entire universe just by simply saying he wants it or even saying an
off lot less than that why bother to go to all this link to say boss it's an incredible mystery
now we're so arrogant and proud and puffed up and all the rest we think we're worth it
okay if you look at it from his angle and the fact that he told louisa she was only an atom
and when you consider it that planet earth is only a speck of a speck of a speck in the universe
I have huge problems and I have to stop and I say lord I can't cope with this at all
if the planet itself is only a speck of a speck of a speck of a speck in the universe
why would you put yourself to this nauseating crisis just for us and to clean us up
it's huge mystery isn't it except for novels yeah but that doesn't explain it
that to me doesn't explain it why did he think we were worth it
it's incredible it is unfathomable well for me it is unfathomable yeah
but I stop every time and I just say lord you know this is beyond anything
yeah is there anybody we would do it for no you wouldn't even think about it
it's absolutely it's mind-blowing the whole thing and that's why if you're doing this in the hours
of the passion do it as slowly as you can sometimes now I couldn't read that amount in
the hours of the passion I'd have to stop after a paragraph and just try and let it sink in
and then then do your praise and your response to the lord you know what I mean
oh yeah it's better than just reading it all and then just saying I'm into the end of it you know what I mean
so I'll do one more for you that's February the 5th 1913 one who does not do the divine will that
does not live in the divine will steals from god because everything in the universe is his
so the difference between divine will and love this is another one with a VIP on it
Jesus told Louisa my daughter one who does not live in my will has no reason to live on the earth
now the only comment I have on that is well
her life becomes without purpose without means and without an end
she's just like a tree that's unable to produce any fruit or at the most it produces poisonous fruits
with which it poisons itself a more and more as well as anyone who would imprudently eat them
this tree does nothing other than steal the poor toils of the farmer who with his hardship and sweat
you don't need the essence is around it to hold the soil in the same way the soul who does not
live in my will is in a continuous attitude of stealing from me and the thefts she makes from me
she converts into poison because it's all self self self so she is around me to steal from me
she steals from me the work of creation the work of redemption and the work of sanctification
with regard to herself that's because she's living entirely encased in herself
she steals from me the light of the sun the food she takes the air she breeds the water that
quenches her thirst the fire that warms her and the ground she treads because all of this belongs
to those who live in my the divine will how's that an incredible and all that is mine is theirs
on the other hand one who does not live in my divine will has no rights and therefore I feel
I'm being continuously robbed so one who does not live in my will must be held as a noxious and
fraudulent stranger can't tell anybody and therefore it's necessary to chain him and cast him into
the deepest prisons these are all these are all the people that are marching the earth demanding
they're right they're right it's very strong but don't forget it's given to you as a contrast
with something else you know what I mean it's not given as some kind of absolute because all of
these people that have been referred to her to or died for them all do you know what I mean so we
have to see it sort of in balance if you if you just simply looked at it without balance to everything
else it would seem very strange indeed because after all I did say to you earlier he loves one
person with the same love with which he loves all you know so Jesus then said my daughter do you
want to know the difference between my will and love here we're back to it again the whole thing is
about divine will and love my will is the sun and love is fire now you know that fire comes out of
the sun my will like the sun has no need of nourishment nor does it grow or decrease in light and in
heat it remains always equal to itself and its light is always most pure on the other hand the fire
which symbolizes love needs wood in order to be fed and if the wood is missing it can even be
extinguished it grows and decreases according to the wood that's placed on it therefore it is subject
to instability and its light is always gloomy mixed with smoke especially if love is not regulated by
my will so having said this he disappeared and a light remained in my mind that this is infused
knowledge through which I understood that the will of God is like a sun for the soul because
the actions that are done as wanted by God form one single thing with the divine will and therefore
the sun is formed the wood that maintains the sun is the human action these are our acts
and one one's own entire being united to the action of the divine being so the soul herself
becomes the wood provided by the divine will and this wood cannot be missing therefore this sun
has no need of nourishment it neither grows nor decreases it is always equal to itself
its light is most pure because it takes part in everything and in the divine being and the divine
wood sorry and the divine being and the divine wood are never depleted and are not subject to smoke
I won't explain further she said because I think that the rest regarding love can be
understood by itself which is a mistake isn't it the thing about love needs to be explained more
than anything else since it's the only thing we can take with us to heaven okay we would leave it
there for tonight